In case we all die,
there is something
that I must
confess to you, Ilana.
Um...
♪
Last summer, um, I switched our
laptop chargers in the night--
during the night,
like a sneaky thief.
And that's why
yours never works.
And I see you try and
you try and you try
and it's
because it's mine.
Oh.
It's never gonna
work, Ilana.
I'm so sorry.
It's not a
big deal at all.
Really?
My God.
You are
forgiveness.
You are.
Wow-- Whew.
Thank you
everybody.
Namaste--
Gracias.
Okay--
I'll continue the game.
Um...
Never have I ever...
read a newspaper.
Really?
Even homeless people
read newspapers.
(Abbi)
Um, I'll
guess I'll go.
Never have I ever...
never have
I ever, um,
dealt with how my parents'
divorce affected my overall,
you know, being in
relationships.
So.
Hey.
Yeah... I mean,
it's an intense subject.
Can I get a bite
of that P-sal?
No, I'm still
working on it.
There's a lot of--
(screaming)
Bevers, calm down.
There's candles
somewhere.
My goodness.
(Ilana)
Relax-- Breathe.
(Jaime)
Calm down, Bevers.
♪ Boonce boonce
boonce boonce ♪
♪ Helicopter
Boonce boonce boonce boonce ♪